foreign
I come from one of the most uh beautiful
places in the world Papua New Guinea
Papua New Guinea is wonderful for many
reasons our Lush vegetation our seas
Islands lakes and forests
also our unique and remarkable cultural
diversity
not to forget our people
and also not to mention our climate it's
basically 27 degrees Celsius
or 80 degrees Fahrenheit every day all
year
we get enough rain but not too much rain
we get enough Sun but not too much sun
and if you were to live there you don't
necessarily have to turn your heater on
in the winter or you don't have to turn
your air conditioning on in the summer
so I grew up in this paradise until I
have to leave home
to attain a modern education away from
my home after some years I returned home
to be with my people
I returned home
importantly to be with my people to
resist against a mining company that was
proposing to extract minerals in the
freedom river which is a major tributary
to the Civic river which is the longest
river in Papua New Guinea
Pacific river is the lifeblood
and is our heritage
the people living around the area are
called cpic interestingly that is our
identity and our existence are
intertwined with this unhurried body of
water this winding River
the Civic is one of the last remaining
intact and pristine fresh water
ecosystem in the South Pacific region
it is a living memory of my ancestors
who arrived on that island 50 000 years
ago
or more than that
we are the indigenous guardians of that
River and so it is our calling to
protect it
from Haram for our children who are yet
to arrive from the future
I went home to to be with my people to
protect our livelihood and our heritage
but here's where the plot twists
when I returned home the first thing I
did was I wanted to build myself a house
people in The Villages understood that I
was away from home for a long time so
they advised me to build a house that
was made of traditional materials using
traditional Knowledge and Skills
many of the houses in my Village still
has
roof made of fetched Sago leaves held
together by cane Vines
and other renewable resources from the
nearby Forest the designs continue to
change over time
because of climate change
but I didn't listen to them you see I
went to a modern school I know more and
I know better so I built my house on
high steel posts
iron Roofing and all modern materials
when my house is finished they came and
told me you are wrong
and funny enough they were right
so in 2021 we had a unusually strong
winds and my house got blown over so it
tilted sideways and I lost some roof
most of the houses in the village only
experienced mild effects of this wind I
was really angry I didn't listen to them
so here I was I have to spend more money
and more technology to get my house back
on its post
in the same year at the end of the year
I went for longer holidays from the town
I worked in to stay in this house that I
built
during the day I found it hard to
breathe because of the the Heat and the
humidity so I found myself spending more
time at my cousin's place whose house
was built using traditionally designed
um
materials collected from the nearby
Forest so
it had better ventilation it was cooler
it was steadier during the wind and it
allowed the sound and the smell from the
river the lake in the forest
to go through it was really Pleasant
is what I know deep down about
sustainable development and about the
Deep wisdom of my ancestors
didn't connect with my head
I was doing what most of us do we get
educated in the modern world modern
education and and we think that for
example climate change can only be
solved by
Science and Technology
or at least Science and Technology alone
think about it the world thrived for
centuries
until logging Mining and other
extractive and destructive development
ripped resources from the Earth
and here we are looking at experts who
advised on that to advise to us about
the solutions for climate change
maybe we need to rethink about the
definition of experts maybe the experts
are the indigenous people who've lived
lifetimes and centuries and have
protected the Earth and who can help
heal and save it now
thank you
so I learned the value of my indigenous
knowledge and traditions the hard way
and I'm not just talking about building
construct in my house for example
um we have practices we're beginning to
understand
that are beneficial to the environment
for instance in my community we have
sacred places which people are
prohibited to go to science is beginning
to find out that these are essential
breeding rounds for Vital plants vital
plants and animals we have practices
which prohibit certain groups of people
to have a certain plants and animals at
certain times
science is beginning to understand that
this was our ancient way which supported
the idea of managing sustainably and
harvesting resources sustainably
we're also beginning to to see that in
our world where we live there is an
emphasis on kinship relationship and
Social Capital which underpins
and Equitable and connected economy and
Society
which is also the currency which my
people still use today
we have spiritual practices which
understands all of this
and Echoes the connectivity of all this
life
I don't want to stand here and
romanticize about my cultural practices
I want to also acknowledge that we've
got remarkable Oneness of this World
created for example will medicine and
internet and many more inventions that
have affected positively some aspects of
Our Lives
however I still want to believe that my
Papua New guinean cultural traditions
and the Pacific's melanesian greater
worldview based on values such as
kinship relationships and connectedness
of all life and non-life forms could be
elevated for solutions for Humanity and
for the planet to thrive I feel that
many cultures and communities around the
world are in such a hurry to alienate
themselves from
from the nature and treat everything as
fragmented bits and pieces that can or
cannot be traded
while many indigenous communities
continue to hold and acknowledge the
world as a complex web of Connections in
which humans us are only a mere part of
we in Papua Nigri for example continue
to honor and acknowledge our ancestors
in our present day in different forms
and we want to remain as the best
Guardians
for our world for other people and our
children who are yet to arrive from
future
we make these decisions because we want
to
protect our resources in another form in
their natural state
so that it can sustain
and help us
we make this decision because this is
who we are because this has always been
the way we lived
so it will be against our Traditions
which I've talked about
for a company or a business to come in
and rip all the resources out we keep
them in the ground so that everyone
benefits and thrive
these Traditions that we have and these
philosophies have guided us for 50 000
years of sustainable development and
will help us in the win of change
so here's my request to you
stop thinking of us as underdeveloped
uneducated uncivilized
and stop insulting our
our home which is which are the rivers
the forests and the lakes by saying
these are also underdeveloped and
underutilized
in fact our forest for example
are the most sophisticated
efficient and effective carbon storage
facility in the world in which no amount
of Science and Technology can beat
and our traditional cultural Traditions
are so sophisticated we've been able to
use these to protect our forests and our
resources
in fact its rampant consumerism greed
imperialism often your way of seeing the
world and seeing us that has hurt the
planet
stop doing what I did stop thinking that
the modern way of building our future
is the best
it probably is a problem too
communities closest
to The Climate crisis are also
communities closest to some solutions
learn from us
try to understand
respect and heed indigenous guardianship
or else like me
the next great win will blow us all over
thank you
[Applause]